The Joe Rogan Experience but you don't
want to that's the thing it's like we've
got to train people to just not talk out
loud just like you don't do in the movie
theater don't do it at a combo comedy
club and don't talk to the comedians
either don't just talk at them well do
you do you think I mean what do you
think about all these crowd work Clips
don't you think we're breeding this 100
very bad situation it's not a bad
situation because it's just how they do
it some people do it that way but it
makes the audience want more of that I
was talking my nieces just went to
college and she has a roommate who's
like 18 years old she's like essentially
a high school okay and she no she was
like what do you think of crowd work and
I'm like it's so crazy that like teenage
kids are like oh crowd work like well
because those are the clips you could
put online because it doesn't burn your
material right because it's a unique
moment right but sometimes I feel like
there's Comics going up there just
trying to get those moments annoying and
then the audience thinks like oh I'll be
part of this well there's Comics a
little tricky too you go to see their
actual act and
you know the thing about crowd work is
it's always funnier when you're there of
course but it's always funnier because
everyone knows it's happening live and
you don't know what's going to happen to
neither is a comedian they know it's
completely improvised well that's why it
works though because obviously comedy's
about getting everybody to be like oh
yeah and if they're seeing it live it
just happened good point so but depala
used to always say that you know I
worked with Nick for years and he'd be
like oh you're funny off the cuff yeah
that's called the [__] being funny
that's easy write some material you [__]
yeah if if you can do both that's great
right but some people only do one or the
other right yeah but there gets yeah
there's there's tricks to it you
definitely don't want to encourage
people to interrupt people who don't do
crowd work though and that's where it
becomes a problem when people are drunk
and they think I'm gonna get on a video
right you know that kind of [__] does
happen now how do you feel about MCs in
New York which is the only city that
does this where the MC goes up and just
asks everybody where they're from and
does almost exclusively crowd work they
never did that in Boston when I was
starting or and they didn't do it here
in Austin really why do they do that in
New York
I don't know it's a New York like New
York Comics they think that's what the
MC does I think part of it is to find
out where everyone's from because
there's so many tourists
but most MC's in New York just do a lot
of crowd work and I've heard people even
be like I don't like hosting because I'm
not I don't do crowd work and I'm like
well you don't have to just [__] go
does anybody not do crowd work does
anybody just go up and say hey what's up
everybody how you doing let me tell you
about my day
I don't think so really when I hosted
this years ago when Artie Fuqua got in
the accident they needed hosts at the
seller so I volunteered and I hosted for
like six weeks and I felt like I was the
only one that just went straight into
material which I think is better because
I find the audience if they're you know
when they're settling in and ordering
and getting their drinks and whatever
figuring out who's sitting where if you
look up and the comic is talking to
somebody they're going okay it hasn't
really started yet he's talking to that
lady but if you look up in the middle of
a bit you're like [__] quiet the show
started that's how I always felt
um yeah
um it the problem with someone talked
into the audience is it does kind of
encourage the audience to talk to some
of the future comedians if they have a
point that the person disagrees with or
if they're getting to a point and you
cut them off because you could say
something you know sometimes like guys
will mislead you with a bit and you're
like what is he saying
oh but some people jump in in the middle
of it right and [__] it up exactly and
they think they can because someone's
been talking to them in the audience
exactly yes and they're like oh this is
a dialogue I got it perfect exactly or
it gives them an opportunity to be
outraged and now this is kind of
encouraged to give feedback it's
encouraged to talk right I also think
that the audience needs to hear the
Rhythm of a few jokes but to me it's
like if you do crowd work for five
minutes and then do 10 minutes of jokes
but sometimes you have an MC where
you're like I am if you're going first
you're like I'm now the first one
telling a joke which is no good I think
the audience needs to hear like oh okay
some bits
yeah I think that definitely would set
everybody else up for the rest of the
night and that's really what the MC
should be doing but some I remember tell
would get annoyed because atel always
wants to know where everyone's from so
he would ask me like where where are
they from and I was like I don't know
and you could see that he was like what
like and there's nothing worse than
upsetting himself New York I know it's
so weird I know that New York has this
one thing where everybody goes and asks
the [__] audience member where
they're from it's very strange or
they're like what are you doing we're
seeing a comic one time and made me
laugh so hard the audience member made
me laugh so hard because the person was
like what are you what are you doing and
they're like I'm at a show what do you
mean what am I doing they're like I'm on
a date I don't get it I just never to me
it's like we're supposed to be doing a
show I don't get why I don't I don't
care what the audience is from or what
they're doing